as a 50-foot Earth's calder effects
basically are with one difference the
Nazis won the war
I hate Nazis they have a weapon like
doomsday weapon to fight our way through
you can't fight your way through an army
and Nazis alone who needs an army when
you got legends
to the head
she's fast faster
this isn't your earth
places on earth X cannot cross over
event snorts with Supergirl Monday at
8/7 central on the seat hey everybody we
got a new crossover trailer it looks
like Oliver has been shopping at the
kryptonite's sporting goods store we
finally get some Kryptonite arrows I
know everybody's been wondering about
that ever since they started crossing
this show's over Oliver looked at
Supergirl they said that he didn't trust
her during the crossover last year but
by the end of that it kind of came full
circle it was already kind of contrived
like if Barry was willing to vouch for
her so much then clearly she couldn't
have been that bad of a person even
though there have been a couple times
that he's made some questionable
character judgments but there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
announce a new winner at the end of this
so just going through the footage they
just do a better job of explaining
what's going on with Earth X the 53rd
earth in this version of the multiverse
I wasn't sure that they were actually
gonna use Nazi paraphernalia because
most of these people that they're
fighting the evil versions of themselves
are SS so it's not like they have to
walk around wearing Nazi armbands but
you can kind of see visually the reason
why they do certain things just so
people who have no idea what's going on
can tell who's fighting who on screen
like you can see the faces of all these
characters so you're like oh those are
the good characters in the bad
characters are all wearing the armbands
if the costumes weren't already take
giveaways
we finally get some more footage of the
Blitz and flash we get a better look at
you know what looks like their doomsday
device room that barry super-speeds into
here you can kind of see all these maps
in the background and all this
technology so as of right now I'm
putting that all on the Blitz and flash
he just seems like the scientist of the
group so if there's gonna be a doomsday
device to be built and he'd be the
person to do that the funny thing about
this I'm gonna assume that this is their
evil version of central city because
there's so many scenes in their evil
version of STAR Labs so everything seems
like it's in relatively close proximity
the main building here where you know it
looks like there are evil fewer rules
over everyone might wind up being earth
X Oliver there was some question about
that after the last trailer because
aside from what we all learned during
history class you haven't seen any kind
of Hitler in any of these trailers but
they did work in some historical footage
but that's really just a
provide context for why their
concentration camps for why this earth
looks like it's gone to complete [ __ ] oh
the Nazis won World War two so now you
see why gypsies father is so paranoid
about other cultures invading their
earth because of stuff like this
although the people that invaded earth
19 seem more like the brood so just
completely different species so this is
just one of 53 different [ __ ] storms but
the main difference is is that it's the
entire planet it's not just like a
couple people in the case of Earth -
this is just taking that idea to the nth
degree most of them are evil with a very
small pocket resistance with the Ray
character citizen cold these other
characters here like the alternate
version of win but the footage does make
it a little bit clearer about what's
going on here like you actually see them
lining up under the bridge here fighting
this horde of Nazis that are coming in
which it probably corresponds to this
footage here of evil Oliver marching in
front of this tank chasing down regular
people so remember last year how they
build the crossover as heroes vs. aliens
like the one-sentence elevator explainer
for what the crossover was this year
it's heroes versus Nazis even though
technically it's a little more
complicated than that
but you get some better pictures of
Supergirl after that big fight with over
girl in the air like her just getting
her ass knocked out and falling down to
the earth the different fights that they
cut into this just seem like they're
from completely different episodes like
this one here with over girl and the
Kryptonite arrow seems like it's from a
different fight than evil Oliver inside
their version of STAR Labs so just to
make it easy I think what they did is is
when you're inside the evil version of
STAR Labs everything is red and that's
how you know to differentiate it from
our version of STAR Labs but the other
thing that we haven't seen in previous
trailers aside from Cisco here in his
vibe gear on the Waverider is the
alternate version of the Waverider there
could be some funny time-travel business
going on here but it does just seem like
this is an evil version of the legends
from the earth X universe chasing down
our legends but if they have a doomsday
device and an evil version of the
Waverider then don't you just wonder if
they would just forgo all that
Terminator style and go back in time to
try and get the Nazis to win world war 2
on our
but there are so many variables when you
change time like that that there's no
way that it would be the exact same
outcome but if you guys haven't seen it
they released a new poster for the
crossover and they're a couple
characters that we haven't seen before
it looks like the earth x people also
have a version of metallo and Red
Tornado on their team and this is an
official poster so I'm just assuming
that they haven't appeared in any of the
trailers because they're still working
on the CG for them so it's like they
have a version of someone walking around
the trailer with a mocap suit but what
might end up happening is is that those
are just people that they'll kill from
the earth X team during the crossover
because right now citizen cold is really
high on my death predictions list for
the crossover but I think you know just
to keep the stakes real they want to
balance that out a little bit so I think
Red Tornado is very literally one of
their red shirts even though he's
supposed to be one of the more powerful
former members of the Justice League
we'll see how powerful this version of
Red Tornado is because Supergirl was
able to defeat him during season 1 on
her show but that was sort of like the
proto version of Red Tornado and they
kind of implied that he would be getting
upgrades in the future if he ever came
back but let me know in the comments
what other big surprises are you
expecting from this crossover but if you
weren't sure as they say in this trailer
it's all happening next Monday in
Tuesday so they're cramming for hours of
television into two nights I think just
because they want it to feel like a big
four-hour movie but it'll be interesting
to see what happens at the end of this
and the way they resolve things
obviously the heroes will be victorious
that's just the way television works but
it'll be fun to see which big upgrades
and changes we see in the characters
aside from the introduction of the Rey
character so rain the freedom fighters
is actually an animated TV show that'll
be the biggest new thing like hey here's
this big new character but aside from
the animated series they're running on
CWC I don't know what their plans are
for him on the live-action shows in the
future maybe a guest spot every once in
a while on one of the TV shows but in
that same vein Constantine is coming on
legends of tomorrow in the back half of
the season for a two-episode arc so if
you weren't sure about other characters
that have been gone for a while there
will be people coming back and they
haven't revealed what the two-part flash
episode is going to be this year too
because they always do that in the back
last year it was the gorilla City
two-part episode this year will be
something different so we'll probably
find out about that during the break
just because they want to get people
hyped up but what will happen is is
after these episodes ere the week after
that will be the mid-season finales of
everything so there's no break so new
episodes next week but also the week
after that then they go on break and
come back in January the one minor
change they're making to the schedule is
is that Black Lightning is going to
premiere right after the flash comes
back that third week in January
so I don't know how many episodes that's
going to run before legends comes back
or if they're gonna put legends on a
different night they haven't revealed
that yet but legends of tomorrow isn't
coming back right away but I've got some
Avengers infinity war Captain Marvel to
post I'll try to get that out by tonight
if I can if not that that'll just post
tomorrow morning but congratulations to
B fam you're the latest giveaway winner
please private message me so I can get
your contact details
I'll just announce a new winner when I
post new DC but you can click here for
last night's flash versus the thinker
episode probably the best one all season
long and you can click here for a brand
new Rick and Morty Thanksgiving teaser
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight